Jew and June got the win she needed to
equalize the score in the fide women's
world championship match going into
round eight the score was 4-3 with
Challenger Lei Ting Jae leading after a
nearly 18-minute think in this position
lay played Rook B3 a move that freely
gave up a pawn the goat Judith Polgar
was shocked to give up some material for
activity but sometimes simply it doesn't
work from here Zhu pushed the advantage
advancing her pieces into Lay's position
and then on move 56 Zhu gave her
opponent the chance to equalize lay had
an opportunity to force a draw by
alternating between Rook D3 check and
Rook D4 threatening to win The crucial
f-pawn though Rook D4 is a very
difficult move to see in time pressure
as it appears to hang a rook but black
can take the Rook on E7 if white
captures The Rook on D4 Zhu took this
opportunity to press and upon
sacrificing The Rook in this position it
was all over that's when